j'ai mis un Zelenski a vu dans ce qui
s'est passé en Russie le signe d'un
chaos et de la faiblesse de ce pays
oui et je pense que même si cela s'est
pour le moment en tout cas résout
peut-être plus rapidement résolu plus
rapidement que ce que beaucoup
d'ukrainien l'espérée c'est le cas de le
dire les mots de volodiumski reste
valable en tout cas pour la plupart des
commentateurs
Ukrainiens
c'est clair que cette épice au démontré
une faiblesse de Vladimir Poutine
quelqu'un qui a monté une insurrection
ouverte contre des membres de son
gouvernement et puis finalement contre
lui-même puisque d'abord quand les FSP a
ouvert
une enquête contre
Vladimir Poutine a fait un discours en
disant que il était un traître que
Prigogine était un très très et qu'il
fallait qu'il soit puni finalement il ne
sera pas puni il aura négocier
certainement il aura obtenu certaines
choses qu'il voulait on l'ignore
exactement mais ça ressemble plus des
règlements de compte entre mafieux que
au fonctionnement d'un État qui se veut
une puissance mondiale alors c'est une
épisode que les Ukrainiens veut et c'est
aussi l'argument qui devait être
présenter au monde montre la faiblesse
de la Russie montre que la Russie est un
état effectivement au chaotique comme
vous le ski lundi tout cela étant dit je
pense qu'il y a tout de même une
ambiance un petit peu de déception à
Kiev parmi certains Ukrainiens qui
avaient osé espérer que
des combats à les héron entre des forces
qu'il allait commencer à s'entretuer ce
qui aurait été clairement à l'avantage
des Ukrainiens sur le front militaire
puisque les russes auraient été obligés
de envoyer des forces loin du front en
Ukraine pour pour assurer la sécurité
pour combattre les forces en Russie donc
cet avantage militaire que l'Ukraine
espérer peut-être avoir dans le court
terme n'a pas matérialisé du moins pas
pour le moment et pendant ce temps
Gulliver la contre-offensive ukrainienne
en elle-même continue les Ukrainiens
revendiquent des avancées dans l'est du
pays
oui juste au moment en fait où précocine
annoncé qu'il allait faire marche
arrière
la vie ce ministre de la Défense qui
communique beaucoup sur la
contre-offensive a dit que l'Ukraine
avait
lancé des opérations offensives qu'elle
a qualifié de massif dans l'est du pays
il s'agit surtout de la partie est
nord-est de la région de donuts que non
loin de la ville de bakkemout ou selon
alamalia il y a des avancées à plusieurs
endroits mais comme toujours ce sont des
informations assez difficiles à
confirmer pas de nouveaux villages de
libérer pour le moment en tout cas mais
il y a aussi cette information
symboliquement importante comme quoi les
forces ukrainiennes auraient traversées
ce qui était la lignée de front entre
2014 et 2022 et aurait pénétré une toute
petite partie de la partie de la région
du Dondas qui est occupé par les forces
russes depuis 2014 une victoire
symbolique purement symbolique pour le
moment puisqu'il s'agit
de 500 mètres pas plus mais tout de même
d'une importance pour le moral des
Ukrainiens l'univers Craig à Kiev merci
beaucoup